was the last show you binged watched for
years now tv has been the new silver
screen with many hollywood stars
choosing television over movies the
split is one of those shows that has
captured that at-home audience including
me i spoke to the director d koppan and
actor fiona button who you may know as
rose
what are you doing tonight
uh
oh god
uh no no it's me it's me i i've been
putting out these really confusing vibes
i was gonna ask if you could babysit
tonight i've got a date okay right well
yes
of course because you're a normal human
being
dean fiona thanks so much for coming in
today to talk to me
about the split um you are to blame uh
for me being very tired at work because
i've binge watched this and stayed up to
three in the morning so it's all your
fault that i've got bags of eyes but
it's an absolutely brilliant
drama
about divorce
uh i think it's been really popular from
what you're saying in terms of how many
people have watched it but i mean i
absolutely loved it we'll get into a bit
more of the characters and as we go
along but dee let's start with you
because it was your debut
as a director yeah and it's been as i
said really successful were you did you
expect to get this type of reception
like when you were making it did you
think this is this is good stuff i mean
every day every day
especially
um no i mean the response has been
extraordinary i think it's been quite
overwhelming actually i you know i knew
it was a really loved show
um which is always slightly terrifying
because when you come onto something
that's the third season
and and you know how many people love
the show you feel a little bit like
you've joined the relay race and you're
doing the final like 100 meters and
you're about to be handed the baton and
you've just got this fear of just like
just don't drop the battle at the last
sort of hurdle but um but yeah so i
definitely felt the pressure of that but
um but you know and i obviously i knew
it was special when we were shooting it
and you know i loved the script so much
and
ibus scripts are incredible and
obviously to to be you know to be
working with such a great cast i
you know i hoped it would do well but it
has definitely exceeded all sort of
expectations i think it's been quite
yeah just quite amazing how well it's
been received and you didn't drop the
bat and in fact i reckon you smashed it
right she absolutely she overtook all
the like other runners and fiona you
you're rose in in the series you're the
the youngest daughter with these two
sort of power
sisters but
my view of it was that you are
the kind of warmest
character really um
what was it like going through
the three series because rose has a
really difficult time
uh in the third series she struggles
with infertility and then she loses her
husband was it was it hard to play
those scenes so if they i mean they made
me cry they were very emotional
yeah um
i
was pretty i mean i've said it before i
was pretty intimidated by the by the
scene where she finds out that her
husband has died i mean it's like a
mixed blessing because you get that as
an actor you get like a something really
big happened to you something you know
tragedy
and you're like yes you know great i get
something to get my teeth into and then
oh god actually but i've got to do it
and i've got to do it well
and i've got to do it believably and do
justice to you know
viewers who've watched it who've lost
their partners and and
and then it just is terrifying so i was
terrified um but it kind of helped in a
way and dee
on the subject of divorce you you might
think of it almost as a subject of box
office poison i mean it's something
that many people go through but it's a
horrible experience
in this series as i was saying the
characters are relatable they're
struggling with problems that many
people struggle with
divorce has actually been quite a
fertile
subject to
to tell stories about right yeah i guess
so and i mean obviously
it's you know it's a testament to abby's
abby's incredible writing with this but
um
you know and obviously this this was
always supposed to be a three series um
show which was always supposed to be can
you have the good divorce so obviously
that yeah that was really the aim of it
i think also she was her aim was i think
the reason why perhaps there haven't
been many dramas about divorce is
because there's always a certain amount
of shame that's attached
and so people don't really want to talk
about their own divorce but
it just so happens that one in three
marriages end in divorce you don't have
to be
a family lawyer from london in a really
fancy house i think it's it's a it's
really a look at love and family and the
messiness of life and it doesn't really
matter where you're from or what your
background but it's you know it's yeah
it's love family relationships divorce
affairs
trying to get pregnant losing a baby
it's you know it's something that
everyone is relatable
people and it feels very raw as well
very raw and very rare and i think
that's a testament that abby's writing
is she's just she's got this such a way
with words that it's it's her dialogue
is so real and so relatable
second visit in as many weeks yeah just
uh clearing out james's stuff
oh
thank you
um
very efficient
yes they do that yeah
must have been hard
oh um oh god no no no i've been longing
to get rid of some of that stuff for
ages
70's afghan coat was never coming back
in
a lot of the projects you've been
involved with being the split bridgeton
the crown they're female-led
is that something
important she worked on projects that
are predominantly about promoting women
or did it just happen by chance i think
it's it's a combination of the two i
think it's yeah it's slightly started
off by chance but i guess it's what
you're attracted to and what you're kind
of interested in and what sort of yeah
piques your interest really but yes i am
yeah i guess that's probably the thing
that turns my head the most but um
obviously not just exclusively on female
projects in the future but i think
coming on board this show was really
exciting because it's a really strong
female team female you know abby morgan
female writer creator exec
two female execs a sister pitchers who
have you know very strong female lead
production company and yeah it was it
was lots of
strong women um in in great positions
making this an email grip
yeah
yeah
female grip as well yeah which is really
rare um for us to have a key key grip
who's a girl so yeah
the whole thing in the industry for a
long time has been that there's an
absolute paucity of of women directing
films that films and series that there's
there's women lots and lots of women
across the industry but when it comes to
those those big those big big jobs it's
been predominantly male did do you do
you feel you get the same opportunities
as your male counterparts or maybe in
the past you didn't but it's changing i
think it's really changing i mean i i've
been quite lucky because i i sort of
came up um
i came up through the ranks and i i used
to self-shoot a lot and do a lot of
camera work so i've i've come up in in
quite a predominantly male
um
area but i but i i kind of i knew my
craft and i was you know it was fine i
never really had any issues really but i
i think there are definitely
more opportunities now and i think there
are some amazing women coming up through
it and obviously we're seeing the
success of so many great female
directors that that's opening doors and
you know it's that sort of sending you
know sending the elevator back down for
the others and i feel that's that's
happening now we're approaching hard
times as a country in terms of the cost
of living
um do you think that in a way that
people are going to want more escapism
that they're going to want more sort of
shows like this where they can just lose
themselves yeah i think i mean i think
so you look at the success of bridgeton
in lockdown as well that wasn't you know
another one that is you know total
escapism uh i think people do love
seeing that but but with this as well it
is
important although they have you know
wonderful amazing incredible lives and
very big houses and wonderful kitchens
and incredible locations they do have
good kitchens
but you know it's still they have all
the same messiness and complications as
everyone else with you know with
certainly in the family yeah and i think
i i think there has been a shift since
the pandemic though i mean i don't know
i can't speak for the entire country
obviously but like i think maybe there's
less cynicism in a way like when we with
our tv choices like we want to watch
something
that has heart and is
isn't ashamed of that and isn't ashamed
to say like we love and we love strongly
and we feel things and
talk about you know feelings in that way
in that kind of explicit way that abby
does and just to end
uh dee
which is your favorite character
present company excluded yes exactly
kicks on that's not you in a minute
that's literally like asking someone to
pick their favorite child kind of i love
you
no no i can't yeah it's just but it's
not that you love them all equal it's
just that you love certain things about
each of them so much and i think you
know any well any show that you do and
you probably feel the same of the things
you pick you have to love the script
you've got to really love the project
because you've got to fall in love with
every character but there's a weird
thing though where uh ruth
it is exactly like my mother it's really
strange which is always always quite
bizarre but um yeah i don't think i can
pee okay
that's fine you don't have to i'm sure
excluding rose
who was your favorite who's your
favorite character carrot
it's so hard because it's hard to
separate the character from the actor
now yeah right okay so so
you know i it it's hard to be like to
talk about them without the performances
because they're so part of who they are
well let me ask you what was your
favorite bit about playing rose how
about that ah definitely
playing with playing with those people
all the time getting to play with
hannah and nina with uh nicola and
annabelle and and debs yeah they're like
the sisters everyone wants really i
thought so thanks so much thanks dee
thanks jonah for coming to talk to us
today thank you very much thank you for
having us loved it thank you thank you